welcome to the future of life institute
podcast
i'm lucas perry today's episode is with
yoshibach and anthony aguirre and marks
the beginning of the continuous
uploading of video content for all of
our new podcast episodes
so if you follow the audio only version
of our podcast
you'll now also be able to see the video
content from all of these interviews
here on this channel
if you're not subscribed to the audio
only version of this podcast
then you can check out the description
below this video to see links to our
spotify and apple podcast feeds
you can also search on your favorite
podcasting platform or
app for future of life institute podcast
this podcast was a lot of fun and in it
we explore whether the universe
ultimately might be computational or
digital in nature
we explore collective coordination
problems incentive structures
and how these all affect civilizational
longevity
we also get into whether having a single
multiple or many agi
systems existing simultaneously is more
likely to bring about beneficial
outcomes from ai
for those not familiar with yosha or
anthony
yosha is a cognitive scientist and ai
researcher working
as a principal ai engineer at intel labs
he was previously at the mit media lab
as well as the harvard program for
evolutionary dynamics
anthony is a physicist that studies the
model of eternal inflation
he is also a co-founder and is the
associate scientific director for the
foundational questions institute
he is also a co-founder of the future of
life institute as well as of mitaculous
and so without further ado let's get
into our conversation with anthony
aguirre and yoshibak
[Music]
all right let's get into it uh let's
start off with a
simple question here what is truth
i don't think that we can define twos
outside of the context of
languages and um so truth is typically
formally defined in formal languages
which means in the domain of mathematics
and in philosophy we have an informal
notion of truth
and or a vast array of them a number of
two theories and
uh typically i think when we talk about
any kind of
external reality but we cannot know
truth in the sense as we can
know it in a formal system what we can
describe
is whether a model is predictive and
so we end up basically looking at a
space of theories and we try to
determine the shape of that space
do you think that there are kinds of
knowledge that exists outside of that
that space for example um do i require a
knowledge
that i am aware
i think that knowledge exists only
inside of a mind that is inside of an
agent that observes
things knowledge is not arbitrary of
course because a lot of
knowledge is formally derived which
means
it has similar structure as a fractal
for instance the mental board factor
where you start out with
some initial conditions and some rules
and then you derive
additional information on that but
essentially
knowledge is conditional because it
depends on some exomatic uh
presupposition that you need to
introduce
of course that doesn't make it arbitrary
it means that
if you make that preset position you get
to
certain types of conclusions that are
somewhat inevitable
there's a set of formal systems that you
can explore
so for instance when we define numbers
the number i think is best understood as
a
subsequent labeling scheme and there are
a number of
subsequent labeling schemes that we can
use and uh
turns out that they have similar
properties and
we can map them onto each other so we
have several definitions for the natural
numbers and then we can build the other
types of numbers
based on this initial number theory and
it turns out that other parts of
mathematics are equivalent to
theorems that we discover in number
theory or many of them are
so it turns out that a lot of
mathematics is looking at the same
fractals in different contexts
in a way mathematics is about studying
simple games and all languages are i
think mathematics
is the set of all languages
you made an interesting statement that
knowledge is something that
uh only exists in the mind of
uh well in a mind so i suppose you're
you're contrasting that with information
or
um so well how how would you think
differently about knowledge or
information how would you draw that
distinction if you do
i think that knowledge is applied to a
particular domain
so it's regularities inside of a domain
and this domain needs to be given
and to have knowledge you need to have a
domain that the knowledge is about
and the domain is given by an observer
that
is defining the domain and it's not
necessarily a very
hard condition in terms of the power of
the mind that is involved here so i
don't require a
subject with a first person
consciousness and so on
what i do require is some system that is
defining the domain
so by a mind you mean something that is
this defining the terms or the domain or
in some way
sort of translating some piece of
information into
uh something with more semantic meaning
i
think a mind is a system that is able to
uh predict information
by uh turning uh coming up with a global
model
thereby making the information
explainable
okay so predict information meaning
there's some
some information stream of input
um and a mind is able to
create models for that stream of input
to predict
you know further elements of that stream
at the moment i understand a model to be
a set of
variances which are parameters that can
change their value
each of them has a range of admittable
values and then you have
invariances which are computable
relationships between these values
that constrain the values with respect
to each other
and the model can be connected
to variances that the model itself is
not generating
which can be parameters that uh enter
the system
from the universe so to speak from the
uh from whatever pattern generator is
outside of that system
and the system can create a model to
make uh the next set
of values that are being set by the
outside predictable
and i think this is how our own
perception works
so in terms of human beings
truth is purely mind-dependent it
requires a human being
for example a brain which is a substrate
that can encode information
it's not mind-dependent it doesn't uh
because it's going to be
uh the same for every mind this
uh the same properties in terms of
information processing and modeling
capacity
you mean it's not brain dependent it is
not subjective
it's not subjective yes so for instance
the knowledge that we derive while
studying mathematics is not subjective
knowledge
it's a knowledge that flows out of the
constraints of the domains
and our ability to recognize these
constraints
so so how does this stand in relation to
um to uh
accounts of truth as being you know
third person
out there kind of floating in the
universe
truths um when we bring in the
dependence of
[Music]
models and minds the first person is the
construct to begin with
right the first person is not
immediately given
it's introduced into the system in our
system
as a set of priors and then we are stuck
with it until we deconstruct it again
but uh once we have understood what we
are believe is no longer a verb right
there is no relationship
between the self and the set of beliefs
anymore
you don't change by changing your
beliefs about a certain domain
you're uh just recognize yourself as a
system that is able to perform certain
operations
and every other system that is able to
perform the same operations is going to
be equivalent with respect to modeling
the domain
so so you think that there's no
i think lucas is maybe getting at a sort
of
claim that there's a more direct access
to uh knowledge or information
that you know that we as a subjective
agent are directly perceiving right
there
there are things that you infer about
the world and there are things that you
directly experience about the world as
you know as an observer
in it so i have some sensory stream i
have
uh access to the contents of my mind at
some level
and these are very direct uh this is
very direct
knowledge that i don't have to
uh well there's a feeling that i don't
have to do
uh a bunch of modeling to understand
what's going on
and there's an interesting question
about whether that's true or not like to
to what degree
uh am i modeling things all the time and
that's just happening at a subconscious
level
yeah like so a primitive version of that
would be like uh how in descartes
epistemology he starts off with
like awareness you start off with uh
being aware of being aware
um so that might include some kind of
subconscious modeling though in terms of
direct experience it doesn't really seem
like it requires a model
it's kind of like a direct apprehension
which may be structured by some kind of
modeling
of course descartes is telling a story
when he writes all this he is much much
further when he writes down the story
right this
is not the thing that he started writing
as a two-year-old and then
uh breaking his path along that line
instead he starts out at a highly aware
state and then backtracks and tries to
uh retrace the steps that he had
possibly taken to get where he was
when we have the impression that parts
of our modeling is immediately given
it means that we don't have any
knowledge about how it works
in other way or uh words we don't have a
model that we can talk about
or that we can consciously access before
we can talk about it
and uh when we become aware of the way
in which we construct representation
we get closer to uh what many
eastern philosophers would call
enlightenment that this
that our ideas become visible
in their nature as representations that
we understand that
uh the everything that we perceive as
real is in fact a representation
happening
outside of our mind and we become aware
of the mechanisms that constructed the
representations
and that allow us to arrive at different
representations if we parameterize
these processes differently
but but the yeah so how
so i'm i'm interested in in this
statement
in comparison to an earlier statement
that you made that uh about what is
you know not subjective when you when
you talk about the construction
of so so there are a whole bunch of
things that i experience
as in you know aware agent
um the the claim that you're making
which i agree with is that
pretty much all of that is something
that i have constructed uh
as something to experience based on some
you know some level of sensory input uh
but but heavily processed and modeled
um and it's it's essentially something
that i'm
almost dreaming in my mind to create
this representation of the world that
i'm
then experiencing um but then
you know there's also a supposition that
we have that there is some
something that is causing the feeling of
objectivity there's there's some
something underlying you know our
individual agents sharing
similar perceptions using similar models
and so on
um so there's of course some
sense some meaning that we ascribe to to
an external world based on that shared
concepts and ideas and and sort of
things that we attribute assistant
existence to that are underlying the
model we construct in our mind
so i guess the question is to you know
what
how do you look at uh
where we draw the line between the the
subjective thing that we're sort of
inventing and modeling in our uh
internal representation and the
objective world is there
is there such thing as a purely
objective world is it all
representation at some level is there
some is there a very objective world
with
you know lots of interesting things in
it and we more or less understand it
correctly as it is like where do you sit
on that spectrum
everything that looks real everything
that has the
property of being experimentable at some
level that
can be in subject of experience is going
to be constructed inside of your mind
there is this issue that uh it's not you
that is constructing it
because you are a story inside of that
mind about that agent
but the uh this i is not the agent
the eye is the representation of the
agent inside of the system
and uh what we can say about the
universe it it seems to be generating
patterns
um these patterns seem to be um
independent
of what we want them to be right so uh
it's not that
all of these patterns seem to be
originating in our mind at least this is
not
a model that makes very good predictions
and there seem to be other minds that
seem to be able to perceive
similar patterns but in a different
projection
and the projection is being done by the
mind that is
trying to explain the patterns so the
universe is projecting
some patterns at your systemic interface
and at your talamos or
at your retina and body surface or
wherever you draw the line
and then you have a nervous system
behind this or
some kind of other information
processing system and our best model is
that is the nervous system
that is identifying regularities in
these patterns and
part of these regularities are for
instance sinks things don't exist
independently of our decomposition of
the universe into things
this doesn't mean that the decomposition
is completely arbitrary because our mind
makes it based on what's salient and
what's
what compresses well but this
ultimately there is just this unified
state vector of the universe that is
progressing
and you make it predictable by splitting
it up into things into separate entities
that you model independently of each
other in your mind and they
exchange information thereby change each
other objects
evolution and this is how we get to
causality and so on
but for instance causality doesn't exist
independently of the decomposition of
the universe into things which has to be
done by mind
well i'm curious as to why you say what
there really is is this
uh this unified evolving state vector i
mean how do you know
i don't so this is the uh
easiest explanation i have difficulty to
make it simpler than that uh but uh the
separation of the universe into objects
seems to be
performed by uh the observing mind
right the alternatives don't make sense
the what you said seemed to attribute
sort of
a greater reality to this idea of a
of an evolving state vector or something
than
other descriptions of the same you know
there are lots of ways we can describe
you know whatever it is that we call
this system that we're inhabiting right
we can we can describe it at the at the
level of
you know objects uh and you know the
everyday level
uh we can describe it at the level of
fields and
and particles and things we could
describe it maybe there's a
string theory description maybe there's
a single
maybe there's a cellular automaton
cranking along
um do you feel that
one of these descriptions is like
more true than the others or do you feel
like these are different
descriptions of the same like different
ways
so the description of the universe as a
set of states
that changes is
the most basic one and then i can say
it seems that i can take the set of
states
and organize it as it was a space right
there's a
certain way to project the state vector
uh you get to a space to something that
is multi-dimensional by taking your
number line and folding it up for
instance into a lattice
and you can make this with a number of
operators
and then you can have information
traveling in this lattice and
then you usually get to something like
particles and uh
if the particles don't have a distinct
location and you just describe the trend
of particles growing then you have
fields
but they all require additional language
that you need to introduce in additional
assumptions
and also uh we find that they're all not
true in the sense that uh there is a
level of description uh where reality
and description fall apart
from each other so uh for instance the
uh
idea of describing the universe is a
minkowski space
looks relatively well at certain scales
but if you go below these scales
you get singularities or in certain
regions of the universe you get
singularities and
you realize you're not living in space
you can just describe the dynamics at a
certain scale usually as space
same thing is true for particles right
particles are a way to talk about how
information
travels between the locations that you
can discern the state vector
so the thing that i'm sometimes
frustrated with philosophers is that
they somehow
think that the notions that they got in
high school physics
are somehow objectively given and they
know electrons and physicists know what
electrons are and there's a good
understanding and we touch them every
day
and then we build information processing
on top of the electrons and this is just
not true
it's the other way around right yeah
i mean all of these concepts the the
more you analyze them and the harder you
think about them the less you understand
them not the more
you know in the sense of for particles
i mean if you ask what an electron is
that is a surprisingly hard answer to
give
you know as a physicist right an
electron is a is an excitation of the
electron field
uh and what is the electron field it's a
field that has the ability to create
electrons
but when you when you don't know this uh
it means uh you
have never understood it right the
person that came up with these notions
have either uh pulled them out of thin
air
or they understood something that you
don't right they they saw something in
their mind that they tried to translate
into a language
that people could work with that allowed
them to build machinery but
that did not necessarily convey the same
understanding
and that to me is totally fascinating
right you learn in high school how to
make a radio
but you don't get the ideas that were
necessary to get somebody the idea
oh this is what i should i should be
doing to get a radio in the first place
right this is not enough information to
let you invent a radio
because uh you have no idea why the
universe would allow you to build radios
and it's not that people experimented
and they suddenly got radios and then
they
tried to come up with a fantasy theory
that would uh project electrons into the
universe
and magnetic fields or electromagnetic
fields to
explain why that radio would work they
did have an idea on how the universe
must be set up
and then they experimented and came up
with the radio
and verified that their intuition must
be correct at some level
and the idea that uh that wolfram has
for instance that the universe is a
cellular automaton
is given by uh the idea that the cellar
law automaton
is a way to write down a turing machine
it's equivalent to a turing machine
sorry did you say cellular automata yes
okay is is a way to to write down a
turing machine
yes so uh there is a cellular automaton
or the number of cellular automata which
are turing complete
and uh cellular automaton is a
general way to describe computational
systems
and since the constructivist turn i
think that
we mostly agree that every evolving
system can be
described as uh some
uh automaton right as a finite state
machine or
uh in the uh unbounded case as a turing
machine
well uh that that i think is not clear
right i think
we it's certainly not the way that
physics as it actually operates
works right we we do all this stuff with
real numbers and calculus and
and all kinds of continuous quantities
and it's always been of interest to me
you know if we suppose that the universe
is
fundamentally discrete or or digital in
some way
it sure disguises it quite well um in
the sense that the
the physics that we've invented based on
so many smooth quantities
um and differentials and all these
things
is is incredibly effective and even
quantum mechanics which
um you know is has this fundamental
discreteness to it and is you know
literally quantum
mechanics uh is all still full of chalk
chock full of real
numbers and and smooth evolutions and
uh ingredients that
you know there's no there's no obvious
way to take
the mechanics you know any of the the
fundamental physics theories that we
that we know and make a nice
analog version of them that that turns
into
the the sorry a nice digital version
rather
that turns into the the analog
continuous version that we know and love
um which is an interesting thing you
know you you would think that that would
be
simpler if the world was fundamentally
discrete and quantum
so i don't know if that's telling us
anything other you know it may just be
historical
that these are the these are the first
tools that we developed and they worked
really well and so that became kind of
the
the foundation for our way of thinking
about how the world works with with all
sorts of smooth quantities
um and it and and certainly
uh discrete quantities when you have a
large enough number of them
you know can act smoothly but it's
nonetheless i think a little bit
surprising how uh
how basic and effective all of that
mathematics appears to be
uh if it's totally wrong if it's you
know essentially fundamentally the wrong
sort of mathematics to describe what
reality how reality is actually working
at the base level
it's almost correct you remember these
stories that protagoras
was very opposed to introducing
irrational numbers
into the code base of mathematics and
even stories that he committed murder to
uh which are probably not true
uh to prevent that from happening and i
think that he was really onto something
the world was not ready yet and uh the
issue i think that he had with this
irrational numbers is that they're not
constructive and what
people didn't have until quite recently
in the languages of mathematics is the
distinction between value and function
and uh classical semantics a value and a
function are basically equivalent
because if you can compute the function
you have a value
and if the function is sufficiently
defined you can
compute it right and for instance
there is no difference between pi as a
function as an algorithm that you would
need to compute
and pi as a value and in this classical
semantics
but in practice there is right you
cannot determine uh the arbitrary many
digits of pi before courier sun
burns out there is a finite number of
digits of pi
that every observer in our universe will
ever know
and that also means that there can be no
system that
we can build or that something with
similar limitations in this regard
can ever build that relies on knowing
the last digit of pi when it performs an
operation
so if you use a code base that assumes
that
some things in physics have known the
last digit of pi before the universe
went on to go into its next state
you are contradicting uh this idea of
constructive mathematics
and uh the there was some hope that this
could be somehow recovered because
mathematicians
before this constructive turn uh just
postulated
this infinite number generator
so uh yeah so your postulate and your
infinite
number calculator the thing that is able
to perform
infinitely many operations in a single
step or read infinitely many arguments
into your function in a single step
instead of infinitely many and
if you assume that this is possible for
instance via the axiom of choice
you get nice properties but some of them
are very paradoxical you probably know
hilbert's hotel
right a hotel that has infinitely many
rooms and is fully booked
and then a new person arrives and you
just ask everybody to
move one room to the right and now you
have an empty room
and uh you can also you have infinitely
many buses coming
and you just ask everybody to roof move
into the room that has twice its current
number
and in practice this is not going to
work because in order to calculate twice
your number you need to store it somehow
and if the number gets too large you're
unable to do that
but it should also occur to you that if
you have such a thing as hilbert's hotel
that you're not looking at a feature
you're probably looking at a bug you
have just invented a cornucopia you get
something from nothing
or you get more from little and that
should be concerning
and so when you look into this in detail
you get to girdle's proof
into the halting problem which uh both
two different ways of looking at the
issue that
when you state that you can make a proof
without actually being performing the
algorithm of that proof
you run into contradictions it means
you can uh you cannot build a machine in
mathematics that runs the uh semantics
of classical mathematics without
crashing that was gordo's discovery
and it was a big shock to google because
he uh strongly personally believed
in the semantics of classical
mathematics and it's confusing to people
like penrose
who thinks that i can do classical
mathematics computers cannot so
my mind must be able to do something
that computers cannot do
right and this is obviously not true so
what's going on here
i think what happens is that we are
looking at too many parts to count
when you look at the world of too many
parts to count
that are very very large numbers you
sometimes get dynamics that are
convergent
right that means that if you perform an
operation
on a trillion objects or on a billion
objects in this domain the result is
somewhat similar
and the domain where you have these
operators and
the way these operators converge this is
geometry by and large
and this is what we are using to
describe the reality that we are
embedded in because the reality that you
and me are embedded in
is necessarily composed of too many
parts to count for us
because we are very very large with
respect to our constituent parts
because otherwise we wouldn't work yeah
all that is true i mean yeah i certainly
again if there are enough of something
and you're trying to trying to model it
that
real numbers will work uh well
you know so but i think
there's um but these are not real
numbers there are
uh very very large numbers this is all
right right but the model is real
numbers i mean that's what we use right
when we do physics we use yes
but it's totally fine when you do
classical mechanics
it's not fine when you do foundational
physics because at this point you are
checking out a code base
from the mathematicians uh that has some
comments by now and the comments say
this is actually not infinite when you
want to perform
operations in there and then you want to
uh prove the consistency of the language
that you're using
you need to make the following changes
which means that pi
is now a function and you can
plug this function into your nearest sun
and get numbers but you don't get the
last digit
so you cannot implement your physics in
such a way
or your library of physics that you rely
on having known the last digit of pi
it just means that uh for sufficiently
many
elements that you're counting this is
going to converge to pi
this is all there is right now i i
understand the motivation for
for thinking that way um and it's
and it's interesting that that's not the
way people actually think you know in
terms of fundamental physics
in terms of you know quantum mechanics
or quantum gravity or anything else
people
but this is their fault this is not our
fault we don't have to worry about them
fair enough fair enough um so i think
the the claim that you're making would
be that
you know if we do um
you know there's a question if a hundred
years from now the the
final theory of physics is discovered
and they they have it
uh you know available on a t-shirt near
them um
you know is that theory going to
you know be a essentially contain a
bunch of natural numbers and
and counting and discrete elements or is
it going to look you know if
if you're of course integers is all that
is computable
right so from so this is a strong
claim about kind of what's what's
ultimately going to happen in physics i
think that you're making which is an
interesting one
and and is you know very different from
what most
practicing physicists in you know
thinking about the foundations of
physics
are taking as their approach yes but
there's
more numbers yes there's a growing
number of physicists
which uh seem to agree with this so very
informally when
i was in banff at a foundational physics
conference i made a small survey among
uh the foundational physicists i got
something like uh 200 responses
and i i think six percent of the uh
accumulated physicists were amenable to
the
idea of digital physics or uh for
proponents of digital physical but i
think is
is really uh showing that this is
growing and attraction
because it's a relatively new idea in
many ways
okay okay all right so um please
seriously
i would try to if i were trying to uh
summarize this and
i guess in a few statements uh correct
me if i got any of this wrong
is that um because you have like a a
computationalist
uh metaphysics yosha uh if
if if reality contains uh continuous
numbers then
uh the states of the
the large vector space can't be computed
is that the
is that the central claim so the problem
is that when you define a mathematical
language
any kind of formal language that assumes
that you can
perform computations with infinite
accuracy
uh you run into contradictions this is
the
conclusion of good okay and uh that's
why i
have to uh i'm stuck with computation i
cannot go beyond computation
hypercomputation doesn't work
because it cannot be defined
constructively i cannot build a hyper
computer that
runs hyper computational physics i think
so it will be stuck with computation
but it's not a problem because there is
nothing that i cannot do with it that i
could do before
everything that worked so far is still
working right everything that i could
compute
in physics until now is still computable
okay so to say digital is to say um
what is that to say it means that
when you look at physics and you make
observations you
necessarily have to make observations
with a finite resolution
and when you describe the transitions
between the observables
you will have to have functions that are
computable
and uh now there is the question is this
a limitation that only exists on the
side of the observer
or is this also an uh limitation that
would exist
on the side of the implementation and uh
now the question is how could
god or whatever hypothetical uh
circumstance
uh perform to do this so if the answer
is
if the universe is implemented in any
kind of language
then it's subject to the same
limitations
uh the only question is could it be
possible that the universe is not
implemented in some kind of language the
question is is it implemented what does
it mean to be implemented we can no
longer talk
about it it doesn't really make sense to
talk about such a thing
we would have to talk about it in a
language that is inconsistent
i lost you there in the last part so uh
when we want to talk about a universe
that is continuous
we would have to define what continuity
means in a way that uh would explain
how the universe is uh performing
continuous operations at least at some
level
and the assumption that the universe can
do this leads into contradictions
so we would have to uh basically deal
with the fact that uh
we have to cheat at some point and i
think what happened before
constructive mathematics was that people
were cheating they were pretending that
they could read infinitely many
arguments into their function but they
were never actually doing it
it was just giving them elegant
notations
and these elegant notations are
specifications for things that cannot be
implemented
and the practice was not a problem
because people just found workarounds in
practice right they would do something
slightly different than the implement
that the notation
and something that i found as a kid very
irritating when i did mathematics
because
sometimes the notation that i was using
in mathematics
was so unlike from what i had to do in
my own mind
or what i had to do on my machine to
perform a certain operation and i didn't
really understand the difference
i didn't understand the difference
between computational mathematics and
why it existed
and the practice the difference is that
the classical mathematics is stateless
it assumes that everything can be
computed without
going from state to state yeah
yeah but it's it's beguiling because you
you you think
there's this number pi and you feel like
it exists
and whether anybody you know computes
the 10 to the 50th digit of it
it has some value you know if you could
compute it
you it would have some value and um
there's no sort of freedom in what that
value was going to be it's
that value is defined as soon as you
make the definition of pi
so go back to this moment when you had
this uh uh idea that
uh pie is there for you with all its
infinite glory
uh this is certainly not an idea that
you were born with right you were
hypnotized into it by your teachers
a day by their teachers and so somebody
at some point made this decision
and uh sure it's not obvious
no it's not but it but it is uh
i mean it's sort of a relic of plato i
guess i mean it goes
uh i think there is
you know mathematicians are obviously
are split in this
in in all kinds of ways but there are a
lot of mathematicians who are blatanists
and really
uh very much think that
pie meaningfully exists in all its glory
like in in that way
so i i think there are probably surveys
that we could consult but i haven't
about
the the degree of platonism and
physicists i
suspect it varies pretty widely actually
now uh take a little step back from
all these ideas of mathematics that you
may or may not have gotten in school
and uh your teachers may not or may not
have gotten them in school
but look back at what you know right
your computer and how your computer
would make sense of the universe if you
could implement ai on it
right this is something that we can see
quite clearly
your computer has a discrete uh set of
sensory states
that it would could make sense out of
right and it would uh
be able to construct models and it can
make these models in
a resolution that is if you want to
higher than the
resolution of our own mind it can make
observation
at a higher resolution than our senses
and there is basically no limit in
terms of not being able to surpass
the kind of model that we are doing and
yet everything in the mind of that
system would be discrete necessarily
right
so if the system conceives of something
that is continuous
if that system conceives of a language
that is continuous
and we can show that this language
doesn't work that it's
uh is not consistent uh then the system
must be mistaken right it's uh
pointing indexically at some functions
that perform some kind of
effective geometry and an effective
geometry is one
like the one in a computer game right it
looks continuous but it certainly is not
it's just continuous enough
relative to the conventional physics
what does a computational view of
physics what is that what is that
changing
nothing if the if the conventional
physicist has made a mistake
it's this uh exactly the same it's just
that conventional physics invites making
certain kinds of mistakes
that might lead to confusion so uh but
in practice it doesn't change anything
it just means that the universe is
computable
and of course it should be because for
it to be computable just means that you
can come up with a model that describes
how adjacent states in the universe are
correlated okay
okay so this leads into the next
question um and let's try and move on
question number two
actually question number three anthony
uh so we're gonna have to
move along a little bit faster and more
mindfully here um you've mentioned that
it's tempting to think of the universe
as part of a fractal can you explain
this view
and uh what is physics according to this
view
so i think that mathematics is in some
sense something like a fractal
so the natural numbers are similar to
the generator function of the mandelbrot
fractal right you take pianos axioms
and as a result you get all these
dynamics
if you introduce a few suitable
operators and
you can define the space of natural
numbers for instance
using addition or you can do it using
multiplication
in the case of multiplication you will
need to introduce the prime numbers
because you cannot derive all the
natural numbers uh just by
multiplication
uh with uh one and zero you you need all
these
elements um the basic elements of this
multiplication space would be the prime
numbers
and now there is the question is there
an elegant translation between the space
of multiplication and the space of
addition so maybe
has to do with the riemann zeta function
right we don't know that
but essentially we are
exploring a certain fractal here
right now with respect to physics
there is the question why is there
something rather than nothing and why
does this something look so regular
we can come up with entropic arguments
right if nothing
would be existing nobody would be asking
the question
also if that thing was irregular we
probably couldn't exist
this uh type of mind that we are and so
on requires
large scale regularity but it's still
very unsatisfying
because this thing that something exists
rather than nothing should have an
explanation that we want to make as
simple as possible
and the easiest explanation is that um
maybe existence is the default
so everything that can be implemented
would exist and maybe everything that
exists at the superposition of all the
finite automata
and as a result you get something like a
fractal and uh in this fractal
there is us this idea that the universe
can be described as
an evolving cellular automaton is quite
old i think it's
it goes back to zeus's christendom and
it's been
formulated in different ways by for
instance fretkin and wolfram
and a few others yeah but again it's
equivalent to saying that the universe
is some kind of
automaton some kind of machine that uh
takes a starting
a core value or starting configuration
and then
or any kind of configuration and then
moves to the next configuration based on
the stable transition function
but but there's a difference between
saying that the universe is a
cellular automata and the universe is
all possible cellular automaton
which you know that that view is held
sort of by
by max tegmark and i think jurgen
schmidt uber and
but you're you're talking more about
that version aren't you that that
exactly if it's not
your fault it just means that uh
wolfram's project of
enumerating all the cellular automata
and taking the first one that produces
the universe that looks like ours
might not work it could be that you need
all of them in a certain enumeration but
it still is a cellular automaton it's uh
it's just one that is much longer than
volcanbotrope
um you're saying all possible cellular
automata is the same as
one cellular automaton yes it would be
one cellular automaton that is the
result of the superposition of
uh all of them
which probably means that uh
long-standing automata uh
only act relatively rarely so to speak
and i have no idea how to talk
about this in detail and how to model
this so this is a very vague intuition
yeah consciousness i think is the
control model of our attention
and human consciousness is characterized
by
attention to uh features that are
taken to be currently the case that we
keep stable in this phase so
we can vary other parameters that we can
make conditional variants in our
perception and so on
and that we can form index memories for
the purpose of learning
then we have access consciousness which
is a representation of the
potential relationship that we have to
these objects
so we know that we are paying attention
to them and we know in which way we are
paying attention to them so for instance
do we single out sensory features or
high level interpretations of sensory
features or hypotheses or memories and
so on and this is also part of the
intentional representation and third we
have reflexive consciousness and this is
necessary because the
processes in our neocortex are
self-organizing to some degree
and this means that this attentional
process needs to know that it is the
sensory
the attention process so it's going to
make a perceptual
uh confirmation of the fact that it is
indeed the attentional process and this
makes consciousness reflexive we
basically check back
am i spacing out or am i still paying
attention
am i the thing that pays attention and
this loop of going back between the
content
and the reflection is what uh makes our
consciousness uh
almost always reflexive right if it
stops being reflexes be drift uh
drift off and often fall asleep like
literally
what would you say that that love that
sort of self-reflexive consciousness is
is experienced by you know
non-human animals um
i mean i'm trying to like do you
consider you know a mouse that
that that probably does not have that
level
of awareness of awareness
not conscious or do you just are you
sort of talking about different aspects
of consciousness some of which humans
have and some of which
other creatures have i suspect that
consciousness is not that complicated
what's complicated is perception
so uh setting up a system that is able
to make a real-time adaptive model of
the world that predicts all sensory
features in real time
makes a a global universe model
and figures out which portion of the
universe model it's looking at right now
and swaps this in and out of working
memory as needed that's the hard part
and uh once you have that and you have a
problem that is hard enough to model
then the system is going to model its
own relationship
to the universe in its own nature right
so you get a self model at that level
and i think that attentional learning is
necessary because just
correlative learning is not working very
well
the machine learning algorithms that we
are currently using largely rely on
massive back propagation
over many layers and the brain is not
only such
not such a neatly layered structure but
it's
has links all over the place and also we
know that
the brain is more efficient it needs
very fewer
instances of observing a certain thing
before it makes a connection
and is able to make inferences on that
connection
and so you need to have a system that is
able to
basically single out the parts of the
architecture that need to be changed
and this is what we call attention right
when you are learning
uh you have a phase where you do a
simple associative learning
usually right after you're born and
before and you form your body map and so
on
and after the initial layers are formed
after the
brain areas are somewhat laid out
and initialized and connected to each
other you do attentional learning and
this intentional learning requires
that you decide what to pay attention to
in which context and what to change and
why
and uh when to reinforce it and then to
undo it
and this is something that is we are
starting to do now in ai
especially with the transformer for
attention suddenly
plays a role and we make models of the
system
uh that we are learning over so in some
sense the attention agent is an agent
that lives inside of a
learning agent and this learning agent
lives inside of a control agent
and the control agent is uh directing
our relationship to the universe
right you notice that you're not in
charge of your own motivation
you notice that you're not directly in
charge of your own control but what you
can do is you can pay attention to
things
and the models that you generate while
paying attention are informing the
behavior of the overall agent
and uh the more we become aware of that
um the more this can influence our
control and this is i think what's meant
by enlightenment once we notice that
we are not directly embedded into the
universe but that we are embedded into a
set of representations about the
universe
and that we can also these
representations uh we
gain more agency
it's also important not to get this uh
gain this urgency to agency too early
right uh if you realize that what you
perceive is a dream that is
generated by your own brain and you are
still at the stage where you think the
purpose is to make the dream
be as nice as possible you're going to
cheat
right you're just going to create
delusions for yourself but you're not
meant to do this you're meant to
uh create the best model of reality that
you can
come up with to act on it as efficiently
as possible
so lucas was asking about the default
state of consciousness um
which is you know we have this apparatus
which we've developed for
a very particular reason you know
survival and
modeling the universe or modeling the
world well enough to
predict how it's going to work and how
we should take action to
you know enhance our survival or
whatever set of
kind of auxiliary goals we might have
but it's not obvious that that manner of
you know that that mode of consciousness
or
or mental activity is optimal for all
purposes
right there if i'm
it's it's certainly not clear that if i
want to do a bunch of mathematics
the the type of mind that enables me to
survive well in the jungle is the right
type of mind to do really good
mathematics it
it's sort of what we have and we we you
know
shunted over to the purpose of doing
mathematics but um
it it's easy to imagine that our the
mind that we've developed
in sort of its default state is
pretty bad at doing a lot of things that
we might like to do once we choose to do
things other than survive in the jungle
so i'm curious what you think about you
know how
how different are or you know a machine
neural architecture could be if it's
trying to do very different things
than what we've developed to do
i suspect that uh given a certain
entanglement
that is uh ability to resolve the
universe in a certain
spatial and temporal uh way and then uh
having a sufficient processing resources
and speed there is going to be something
like an optimal model
that we might be ending up with and
humans are not at this level of the
optimal model our brain is still a
compromise
i think so we might benefit from having
a slightly larger brain
i think that the differences between
human performance are
differences in innate attention so
talents are basically differences in
innate attention
and you know how they say how we
recognize an extroverted
mathematician they look at your shoes
and what this alludes to is that good
mathematicians tend to have aspergers
which means that they are using parts of
their brain that
normal humans use for social cognition
and for worrying about what other people
think about them
for thinking about abstract problems and
often i think that the focus on analytic
reasoning is a prosthesis for the
absence of normal regulation that is if
you are a nerd
and you have as a result a slightly
different interface to the social
environment than the normies
um you as a child don't get a manual on
how to deal with this
and so you will act on your impulses on
your instincts and unless you
are surrounded by other nerds you tend
to fail in your social interactions
and you will experience guilt shame and
despair and this will motivate you to
understand what's going on and
because as a child you typically don't
have any tools to
reverse analyze yourself and or even
notice that there is something to
reverse engineer
you will turn around and reverse
engineer the universe
yeah i i suspect that there's you know
if we were able to have the experience
and maybe someday we will with
with some sort of you know mind-to-mind
interface of
of sort of seeing actually experiencing
someone else's
you know world view and and processing
reality through their
apparatus uh i suspect we would find
that it's
much more different than we suppose on a
you know on an everyday level
you know we sort of assume that people
are are understanding and seeing the
world more or less as
we are with with some variations uh
and i would i would love to know how to
what degree that that's true you know
you you read these
uh or i read these articles of you know
there are some people who
cannot imagine visual images um and
there are people you know i compare with
my wife when she imagines a visual image
it
you know in her mind it is right there
in detail she can
you know experience it sort of like i
would experience a dream or physical
reality when i think of something in my
mind it's quite vague
and then there are other people who
there's sort of nothing there
um and that's just one one aspect of
cognition
uh i would really love to know and and
i think there would be a fun project to
to really map out
what that sort of range in qualia
really is in among human minds um
i i suspect that it's much much bigger
than we
you know really appreciated by might
cause us to have a little more
understanding for other people if we
understood how
literally differently they they
experience the world than we do
um or it could be that that it's very
similar that would be fascinating too
um the degree i mean we do all function
fairly well
in this world so there has to be some
uh some sort of limit on how differently
we can perceive and process it
um but i i yeah that fascinates me how
how big that wide how big that range is
um i have similar observation with my
own wife who is an artist
and she is very good at visualizing
things
i uh but she doesn't know this external
perception as much
and uh compared to with a highly
perceptive person i think i have
about as about 20 of their sensory
experience
because i'm mostly looking at the worlds
with conceptual reflection i have a
fantasia so outside of dreams or
hypnagogic state i cannot visualize uh
or don't get conscious access to my
visualizations
i can draw them so i can make designs
but uh for the most part i cannot make
art
because i cannot see these things i can
only do this in a state where i'm
slightly dreaming
so uh it's also interesting to notice
the difference it's not
that i focus on this and it gets more
and more plastic and at some point i see
it it's more like it's being shifted in
from the side
it's similar to when you observe uh
yourself falling asleep
and you manage to keep a part of
yourself online to track this
uh without preventing you from going to
sleep which is sometimes hard right
but if you pull it off you
might notice how suddenly the images are
there and they more or less come from
the side
it's right it's uh something is shifting
in
and it's uh taking over
i think that there is a limit to because
anthony brought this up
to how it makes sense to understand the
world and in the way that we operate
uh it's just that we often tend not to
be completely aware of it during the
first 400 years or so
so it takes time to uh reverse engineer
the way in which you operate for
instance
uh and it took me a long time to notice
that uh the things that i care about are
largely not
about me as an individual so i mean uh
of course you all know this because it's
a moral prerogative that
you uh don't only care about yourself
but also about the greater whole and
future generations
but what does that actually mean and you
are basically an agent
that is modeling itself as part of a
larger agency
and so you get a compound agent and a
similar thing is
true for the behaviors in your own mind
they are not seeing themselves as
all there is but they uh at some level
model that they are part of
a greater whole of some kind of
processing hierarchy and control
hierarchy
in which they can temporarily take over
and run the show
but then they will be taken over by
other processes and they need to
coordinate with them and they're part of
that coordination
and this goes down to the lowest levels
of of the way in which this is
implemented
and ultimately you realize that
you have um information processing
systems
on this planet uh which coordinate
for instance uh the an organism or that
coordinate the cooperation between
organisms or that cooperate
cooperation with ecosystems and this is
the purpose of our cognition in some
sense it's
the maintenance of complexity so we can
basically shift the bridge shed of order
into the domain of chaos
and this means that we can harvest neck
entropy
in regions where dumber control systems
cannot do that
that's the purpose of our cognition and
to understand
our own role in it and the things that
matter uh is
the task that we have and there are some
prayers that we are born with so
ideas about the social roles that we
should be having the things that we
should care about
and should not and over time we replace
these priors these initial reflexes
with concrete models and once we have a
model in place we turn off the reflex
so you you don't think that the
expression of proxies and evolution
means that harvesting neg entropy
isn't actually what life is all about
because it becomes about other things
once we gain access to
proxy rewards and rational spaces and
self-reflection
i think it's an immediate phase where
you think that the purpose of
existence is to for instance i must
knowledge or to have
insight or to have sex or to be loved
and love and so on
and this is uh just before you
understand what this is instrumental to
and ultimately right but like you start
doing those things and they don't
contribute to that entropy
they do uh if they are uh useful for the
uh for
your uh performance as the living being
or for the performance of the species
that you're part of or the civilization
or the ecosystem then they serve a
certain role if not
then they might be statistically useful
if not then there might be a dead end
yeah yeah yeah that makes sense um yeah
yeah i don't know i
i mean life is quite good at extracting
neg entropy or information from its
hidden troves supplied by the sun
um you know i don't think we're ever
going to compete with plankton
you know at least not anytime soon maybe
in the in the distant future
um it seems like a little bit of a of an
empty
it's hard for me to get because you're
competing with plankton right
we are able to settle surfaces that
simple organisms cannot settle on
and we're not yet interested in all the
surfaces we are just one species on this
planet
right i don't know i i guess if i beat
the plankton at some point
i'm just not that excited about that i
mean i think there
the it's true that you know to sustain
you know as life we have to be able to
harvest
that you know transform that information
from from the
form that it's in to an ability to
maintain our own homeostasis and
and you know uh fight the second law of
thermodynamics essentially and
and maintain a structure that is able to
do you know but i
but that's metabolism i and
is i think sort of the defining quality
that life has
um but i i i guess i i it's hard for me
to see that as more
than a sort of means to an end in the
sense that
um you know that enables all of the
activities that we do
but you know if you told me that you
know someday our species will create
you know will process this much entropy
instead of that much entropy
that's fine but but i it i don't know
that doesn't seem terribly exciting to
me
just like discovering a gigantic ball of
plankton and space
i wouldn't be that impressed with it um
so i to me i think there's something
more interesting in our ability to to
create sort of information hierarchies
um where there are
you know not just the amount of
information but
but information structures built on
other information structures um
which biological organisms do and we do
you know mentally with all sorts of
meant you know civilizational artifacts
that we've created
and that that the level of hierarchical
complexity that we're able to achieve
seems to me more interesting than just
the the ability to
to like effectively metabolize a lot
we don't need to know that as an
individual we are relatively small
inconsequential we just need to uh know
what we need to know to fulfill our
whole role but if the civilization that
we are part of doesn't understand that
it's in a long-term battle about entropy
uh then uh it is in a dire situation i
think
there's so much there's so much fuel
around i just think um you know we have
to figure out how to
how to unlock a little bit better but um
you know the we are not going to run out
of neg entropy
no uh life is not going to write out of
neck entropy uh it could be that we are
running out of
uh the types of food that we require
and the climates that we require and the
atmosphere that require to survive as a
species
sure but uh that is not a disaster for
life itself
right cells are very hard to eradicate
once they settle the planet
even if you have a super volcano
erupting or a meteor or hitting the
earth
it's probably not going to turn sterile
anytime soon and
so from the perspective of life uh
humanity is probably just an episode
that is
uh exists to get the fossilized carbon
back into the atmosphere
so let's pivot into agi who might
serve as a way of uh locally
optimizing the increase of entropy for
the
milky way and hopefully our local
galactic cluster
um so yoshi so how do you view the path
to
aligned agi
if you build something that is smarter
than you the question is
is it already aligned with you or not if
it's not aligned with you you will
probably not be able to align it at
least not in the long run
the uh right the alignment is in some
sense about what you should be doing
under the circumstances that you are in
when we talk about alignment in the
human society
there are objective criteria for what
you should be doing if you are part of a
human society
right it's given by a certain set of
permittable aesthetics and aesthetic is
a agrees of both that might emerge over
your initial preferences
and there are a number of local optima
maybe there's even a global optimum in
the way the species can organize itself
at scale
and if you build an ai the question is
is it able to would it be interested
would it be in the interest of the ai to
align itself
with this global optimum or is one of
the existing local optima
and what would this look like it would
probably look like a
different from our intuitions about what
society should be like
right we clearly lost the plot in our
society every generation since the last
uh
war has fewer intuitions about how the
society actually functions and what
conditions need to be met to make it
sustainable
sustainability is largely a slogan that
exists for
pr purposes for uh people in the un and
so on
it's nothing that people are seriously
concerned about we don't necessarily
think about
how many people can the planet support
and how can we reach that number of
people
uh how would we make uh resources
be consumed in closed loops these are
all questions that are not really
concerning
the idea that we can eat up the
resources that we depend on
in this especially the ecological
resources that we depend on
is relatively obvious to
the people that run the machines that
drive our society
so we are in some sense in a locus mode
in a swarming mode
and this swarming mode is going to be a
temporary phenomenon
and uh it's something that we cannot
stop we are smart enough to understand
that we are in the swarming mode and
that's probably not going to end well
we are not obviously smart enough to be
able to stop ourselves
so um it seems like you have a quite a
pessimistic view on what's going to
happen over the next uh
100 to 300 years uh maybe even sooner
i've
uh i think i've heard you say somewhere
else that um we're so intelligent that
we
burned 100 million years of trees to get
plumbing
yes this is in some sense the situation
that you're in right it's it's extremely
comfortable uh there has never been a
time
uh in yeah of the entire planet where
species were so comfortable as us
but but i mean why so pessimistic in
that
i'm not pessimistic i think it's just uh
if i look at the
uh possible trajectories that we are in
uh is there a trajectory in which you
can make ourselves
uh enter a trajectory of perpetual
growth
very unlikely right is there a
trajectory on which we can make the
uh thing that we are in sustainable
without going through a population
bottleneck first which will be
unpleasant
unlikely it's more likely than the idea
that we can have eternal growth it's
also not impossible that we can have
something that is close to eternal
growth
it's just unlikely fair
what i find frustrating is that
it's pretty clear that there are no
serious technological impediments to
having
you know a high
quality sustainable steadily growing
civilization
um the the impediments are all
of our own making you know it's it's
fairly clear what we could do
um there's something problems that are
quite hard
there's some that are fairly easy global
warming we really could solve if we
uh you know if if we could coordinate it
just do
the things that that are fairly clearly
necessary to do
that's a solvable problem you know
running out of easily accessible natural
resources
is harder because you know you have to
get closer and closer to 100
recycling um if you want to keep
growing you know the material economy
um while staying within the same
resources
but it's also true that what we're doing
is not you know it's not so much
it's not so clear how much we have to
keep growing the material economy you
know when i look at my kids
um they compared to when i grew up
they barely have any things you know
they
they're not that interested in things um
the most of the things you know there
there are some that they really like but
you know if i buy even five years ago
and i would buy my younger son a toy
he'd play with the toy for like you know
a little while and then he'd be done
with the toy
and i'd be like why did i buy that toy
um they're
much more of their life than ours is
digital
you know and and is consuming media and
it's
you know that seems to be the trajectory
of humanity at some level as a whole
and so it it's it's unclear
you know it it may be that there are
ways in which we can continue
uh economic and growth and
sort of quality of life even while the
actual amount of material goods that we
require is not sort of
uh exponentially increasing in that in
the way that
you would think so i i'm
i share your pessimistic pessimism as to
what's actually going to happen
but i i am maybe more frustrated by how
uh it wouldn't be that hard to make it
work if we could just get our act
together
this getting our act together is the
actual difficulty i know right because
putting your act together as a species
means that you as an individual needs to
make decisions
that somehow influence the incentives of
everybody else
because everybody else is going to keep
uh doing what they're doing right this
argument if everybody would do as i say
that is not
valued for and therefore you do it it's
not a valid argument
no no right this is this is not how it
works so
in some sense everybody is working based
on their current incentives
and what you would need to do is uh to
change incentives
within the means that you as an
individual have of everybody else to
bring about this difference in the
global incentive structure
so it comes down to uh in some sense uh
implementing a world government uh that
would subdue everything
under some kind of eco-fascist uh
guideline
and uh the question is would ati be
doing that so you could uh
it's very uncomfortable to think about
it is certainly not an argument that
would be uh interesting to entertain for
most people
and it's definitely nothing that would
get a majority right it's just
probably what needed to be done to make
everything sustainable i do think that
there are
like within reach technological advances
that that are
sort of genuinely better along every
axis like you know once
um as as has happened
you know photovoltaic energy sources are
just
cheaper now than than fossil fuel ones
and once you cross that threshold
there's just there's no point um you
know maybe five or ten years from now
there simply won't be any point at all
in making fossil fuel energy sources
once
so so there's there's sort of thresholds
where
um the the right thing actually just
becomes
the default and the you know the
cheapest
and there isn't any tension between
doing what we should do as a
civilization and doing what people want
to do as an individual
now it may be that they're always sort
of show stoppers
that are important and where that hasn't
happened or isn't possible
um but it's it's not terribly obvious
that there are i think there there are a
lot of
um there seem to me to be a lot of
systems where
with some careful architecting the
incentives can be aligned
well enough that people can do more or
less what they
selfishly want to do and nonetheless
contribute to
a more sustainable civilization but it
it seems to require a level of
kind of planning and
and creativity intelligence that we
haven't quite
gotten together yet do you think that
there's an optimal number of trees on
the planet
probably right an optimal number of
trees yes
well that would be the most official one
for the ecosystems on earth
and everything else what happened which
happens on earth
right if there are too few trees uh
there are some like entropy
uh which you are leaving on the table if
there are too many um
then uh something will go out of wreck
and uh some of the trees will eventually
die and so in some sense i think there
is going to be an optimal number of
trees
right no well i think there you know
this is a there are lots of different uh
i would say there are lots of different
systems
uh with preferences that
will not all agree on what the optimal
number of trees is and i i don't think
there's a solved
problem for how to aggregate those
preferences and of course no i don't
mean that we
don't usually know this number or that
it's easily discernible or that it's
even stable
right i'm not even transported i mean
how
i don't think there is a answer to how
to aggregate the preferences of a whole
bunch of different
agents and so i'm not sure how oh it's
not about preferences ultimately the
preferences are instrumental to
complexity
basically to uh how much life can exist
on the planet
how much neck entropy can you harvest
ultimately there is no meaning right the
universe doesn't care if something lives
inside of it
not uh but from the perspective of
cellular life
um what evolution is going for
is in some sense um an
attempt to harvest the neck entropy that
is available but we don't have to listen
to evolution
of course no
but if we don't do this it probably is
going to limit
uh our ability to stay
because we are part of it it's uh we are
not the
highest possible life form they are
going to be uh
if uh apes are some kind of a success
model
uh descendants that are not going to be
that human like
if we indeed manage to leave the gravity
well not just send ais out there
it turns out that uh there can be
descendants of us that can live in space
that will probably not look like captain
kirk and uh lieutenant yahuwah
but uh in far future ai the the
commanders of space fleets will look
very very different from us they will be
very different organisms right they will
not have human aesthetics
they will not solve human problems they
will
live together in different ways because
they interface in different ways and
interact with technology in different
ways
it will be a different species de facto
and so
if we think about humans as a species we
do
depend on a certain way in which we
interface with the environment in a
healthy sustainable way
and so i suspect that there is an is a
number uh
of us that should be on this planet if
we want to be stewards of the ecosystems
on this planet it's conceivable that we
can travel to the stars but probably not
in large numbers and
you're not the optimal form right if you
want to settle mars for instance we
should
uh genetically modify our children into
something that can actually live on mars
so it should be something that doesn't
necessarily need to have an it seems to
me that yes
it should be able to hibernate it should
be super hardy it should be very fast
uh and uh be able to uh feed on all the
proteins that are available to it which
are
outside of earth mostly humans right so
it should look like alien in in the
alien movies
well again i i think that's a choice i
mean i think we
i mean you can argue that that once you
have different
uh that that will be an inevitability
because
it's not inevitable you can always make
a sub-optimal choice and then you can
try to prevent everybody else to
make a better choice than you did and if
you're successful then you might prevail
but if you are an environment where you
can have free competition then in
principle your choice is just an
instrument of evolution
can we relate this this this global
coordination problem of
beneficial futures to agi
and particularly uh yoshi you you
mentioned uh an eco-fascist
agi um so
a scenario in which that might be
possible with something would be
something like a singleton
yeah so i'm taking this question from
from anthony
so anthony asks if you had to choose
knowing nothing else
a future with one several or many agi
systems which would you choose and why
and how would you relate that to the
problem of um
global coordination control for
beneficial futures
there might be a benefit in having
multiple atis which could be
the possibility of making the individual
ai model
one of the benefits of mortality is that
whatever mistakes
a single human makes or it's over after
a certain while so
basically um uh for instance the mongols
allowed
their kinds to have absolute power and
override all the existing institutions
right this was possible for doing this
kind but uh
they basically tried to balance this by
uh if this person died they
would stop everything that they were
doing and reconsider
right and this is what stopped the
mongol invasion so yeah thank goodness
for europe right
right so it was very lucky but
of course they wouldn't have needed to
do this right and a similar thing
happened with
uh stalin for instance right stalin has
burned down russia in a way or
most of a lot of the existing culture
and it stopped after stalin
it uh it didn't stop immediately and
completely but stallionism
basically stopped with stallion and uh
so
in some sense uh this mortality is on a
control level adaptive
center sense is adaptive as well right
so we don't out compete our grandkids
but uh we see this issue with our
institutions they're not mortal
and as a result they become stannis and
because uh they basically have mission
creep they're no longer on the same
incentives they become more and more
postmodern
once an institution gets too big to fail
the incentives inside the institution
change especially the institutions
the incentives for leadership so uh
something that starts out very
benevolent like the fda turns into
today's fda
and if the fda was mortal right we would
be in a better situation than the fda
being an ai
that is sent here it's just acting on
its own incentives forever
right the fda is currently acting on its
own incentives which are poorly aligned
increasingly poorly aligned with
uh the interests that we have um in
terms of what we think the
fda should be doing for us when it
governs us or
governs part of us and that is the same
issue
with other agis in some sense the fda is
in uh agi with humans in the loop
and uh if we automate all this it uh
turn it completely into a rule base
uh especially a self-optimizing rule
base then it's going to
align itself more and more with its
incentives so if we have multiple
competing agents
we can basically prevent this thing from
calcifying to some degree
and we can have the opportunity to build
something like a clock into this that
lets the same die at some point
and uh to replace it by something else
and
we can decide uh once the thing dies by
itself
uh what this replacement should look
like if it would be the same thing or if
it should be something slightly
different so this would be a benefit but
outside of this
it's not obvious right from the
perspective of a single agent it doesn't
make sense that other agents exist
for a single human being the existence
of other human beings seems to be
obviously beneficial
because we don't get that old our brains
are very small we cannot be everywhere
at the same time
so uh we are depend on the interaction
with others
but if the you leave the uh lose these
constraints if you could turn yourself
into some kind of machine that can be
everywhere at the same time
that can be immortal that has no limit
on its information processing it's not
obvious by you should not just be
solaris the planet-wide intelligence
that is controlling the destiny of the
entire planet
and why you would get better if you had
competition
right ideally you want to subdue
everything once you are
a planet white mind or a solar system
white mind or
galactic mind if that's conceivable
well so there are two two elements of
that one is
what the what the ai would want and the
other is
right yes uh that seems perspective one
is you have an a uh
in mind that is infinitely scalable this
mind that is infinitely scalable would
not want to have any competition at
least that's
not obvious to me it would be surprising
to me if it wanted to
if you you have non-scalable minds like
ours that co-exist with it then from the
perspective of these
non-scalable minds it would be
probably beneficial to limit the
capacity
of the other minds that we are bringing
into existence
which means people would want to have
multiple of them
so that they can yeah i mean they can
compete and then uh that we can turn
them off
without everything breaking down well
it's tricky because
that competition has is a double-edged
sword they can you know they
they can compete in the sense of being
able to limit each other but
creating a competition between them
is then seems necessarily going to
uh incentivize them to enhance
themselves
more when they you know you so when you
have uh amd and intel competing we
consider this to be a good thing right
when you have apple and microsoft
competing we also consider this to be a
good thing if we had only one of them
they would not be incentivized to
innovate anymore and a similar thing
could happen for instance uh
if we had just one fda we have two fdas
so the fda becomes like an app and uh
it's you have some central oversight
that makes sure that you always get
inside of the box what's written outside
of the box
but beyond that uh the fda's could
decide whether they for instance allow
you to import
a medication from canada or not uh
without an additional
trial and basically uh people would
subscribe to
the fda they're like better and we would
have constant innovation and regulation
but it's that's a very managed
competition so
it's less clear that the us soviet union
competition
is something that we that was good to
encourage in that sense and that that
from the perspective of central europe
it was great right the cia
helped the west german unions to make
sure that the west german workers had a
lot to lose
and uh eastern germany was best off
among all the
east bloc countries exactly because of
this competition it was great given that
we managed to
to not have a nuclear war but or or a
land war
but i think um i mean the concern i
think is
that i have is yes if you have a managed
competition that tends to be good
uh you can sort of set the rules you can
uh
there there's there's a ability to
forestall some sort of runaway process
when the competition is kind of at the
highest level for the
the overall uh
what will play what has sort of the
overall highest level of power
in the whole arena um then that's a lot
less clear to me that the competition is
going to be a positive thing
governance has become dramatically worse
since the end of world war ii
since the end of the cold war right it's
uh
there seems to be an increased
sense that it doesn't really matter what
kind of foreign policy we are driving
because it's it's largely uh an attempt
to gain
favors with the press you can win the
next election so it's about
selling points it's not about whether uh
a regime change in libya is actually
good
who cares well i think that that's a
decoupling between
the government actions and and our
you know we we don't have to actually be
effective as a society
we sort of uh exactly because we don't
have competition anymore so once you
take competition of the table you lose
the incentives to perform well
those incentives could be
redirected in some way i think but we
haven't figured out a good way to do
that
the only way we figured out to create
the right incentives are the competition
structure
i agree with that um if we were a little
bit more enlightened we would understand
that we still have to be effective
um well i think we would personally
understand this
this problem is that if you are trying
to run on a platform of being effective
against the platform that runs on being
popular
and uh the only thing that matters in
the incentive structure is popularity
then the popular uh platform is going to
win uh even worse when
uh once you manage to capture the
process by which the candidates are
being selected you don't even need to be
popular
you just need to be more popular than
the other guy is it possible for the
incentive structures to
you know come strictly internally from
the ai system
uh it's unclear to me what you know
if it actually has to come from from
competition in the real world pushing it
to
uh optimize harder um could you not
create similar incentive structures
internally
uh the question is how can you set the
top level incentive correctly
ultimately the if you as long as you
have some dynamic in the system
um i suspect the control is going to
follow the incentives
and when we look at the failure of our
governments
they're largely not the result of the
government being
malicious or extremely incompetent but
mostly just everybody at every level
following their true incentives
and uh but do you think i don't know how
to how you can change that
do you feel like there's a a natural or
default or
unavoidable set of incentives that a
high level
ai system is going to feel then like
only if it sticks around
right it doesn't have to uh stick around
there is no meaning
in existing it's uh only the systems
that persist tend to be
set up in such a way that they um
act as if they want to persist
well i guess my question is you know to
what level are the incentives that a
system has
um you know normally the the incentives
that a system has are kind of set by its
context
and and the the system that it's
embedded in if we're talking about a
sort of world spanning ai system
it's not clear it's sort of in control
so so it seems
like the normal model of this the
incentives being set by the other
sort of players on the stage is going to
apply and it's
it's not clear to me that there's a sort
of intrinsic
set of incentives that are going to
apply to a system like that
so when we act we act uh based on
incentives right on what uh this means
that we have to make certain commitments
this is uh there are certain things that
should rather be the case
instead of not be the case right and
these commitments
uh once you have them they define in
which direction you have to go
uh once you make them consistent with
each other and translate them into some
kind of global aesthetic some word state
word dynamic that is compatible with
these preferences
and without such a global model you
probably don't know what you're doing
and you're being outmodeled by other
systems that understand
in which way you are diluted so
you basically need to find a set of
identification that is sustainable that
is
modeling the dynamics that you're part
of so for instance when you
decide to model yourself as part of a
sustainable civilization
uh it is that only makes sense to the
degree that this sustainable
civilization can be instantiated by your
actions
and uh supported by your identifications
right so uh the sustainable civilization
is probably something that needs to
be willing to enable to plan a few
generations into the future and act on
the models that you get
and unlike hours where all the
projections somehow stop in 2100
and uh this is also true for an agi that
basically the adi would need to be
wanting to stick around
and uh in the same way as you and me
want to stick around maybe not
necessarily as individuals but
uh in the sense that the actions that we
are contributing to our species
uh remain as an echo in our species and
the species is the thing or the
civilization is this thing that matters
that we try to support and
keep around right so to the degree that
our actions uh
are able to serve that goal of our
civilization sticking around or our
species sticking around or life on earth
sticking around or intelligence and
consciousness sticking around this is
the degree to um which we can talk about
whether you're effective or not
and if an individual doesn't subscribe
to this they are probably not going to
be effective with respect to that long
term goal in the same way as those that
are now uh
how could we bring such a sentient
civilization about
incentives here means that you have an
agent that understands it
uh what it is what uh its role in the
environment is but its relationship to
the surrounding universe is and what the
surrounding universe is
right it's something that we also
struggle for when we try to understand
our relationships to the underlying
physics
is part of us becoming sentient when we
try to reverse engineer our own mind
with the tools of ai ditto when we try
to
get society to work it's also a part of
that goal right
you want to stick around as a thinking
being as an experiencing being
or as uh be part of that greater thing
that is experiencing things
and making sense of them and now the
question would be uh what role is ai
going to play here
one was obviously um building ai helps
us to understand ourselves
there is this big danger if we make a
non-living intelligence
right if you teach the rocks how to
think are the interests of the rocks
aligned
with ours wouldn't it be better for uh
ais to sterilize the planet and just set
up solar cells everywhere
i don't know that right it's a big
danger i suspect that
technological civilization could turn
out to be a debt and and the correct
solution would have been to go or
biotech
so uh the way to make humanity
sustainable is to breed some kind of
queen bee organism
that is that we are serving it lays a
little egg into all our brains
and it will look completely adorable to
us and sacred
and uh it's going to live for very long
and it's going to depend on us
that we feed it and uh our obey its
commands
right so it keeps us around as a species
we're going to transition to being a
hive mind species
yeah maybe um okay
this is the good outcome okay um
how would you view the role of uh
non-duality both metaphysically and
experientially here
in in in terms of what you've just
talked about
and particularly in the role of
like potential collective coordination
if
if non-duality were collectively
realized so this is like closer to
a hive mind is that is that a
is that a possibility i think that
non-duality
is a state in which you are mutually
recognizing that you have the same
interests and the same purposes
and it falls apart in the moment when
you realize that you do have different
interests
right so if you're competing for the
same partner then your non-duality is
going to break down at some level
unless you basically share your
interests again and you decide that
uh this competition is meaningless and
uh there is an optimal solution for uh
the distribution of relationships
right and you all agree on this in a
mutually beneficial way
so it's basically a stance it's it's not
something that is
fundamentally changing the way that you
are relating
to reality once you get to a certain
level of awareness it's the stance that
is available to you
so everybody who is able to understand
how their self is being constructed i
think is able to enter this state that
people call
non-duality it's just when people do
this for the first time it typically
happens in a very protected environment
uh in which there are no conflicting
interests and somebody makes sure
that nothing goes wrong
okay so your view is that people who
abide in for example stable
uh non-dual states that they
you know still have their own interests
and the you know they're going to act in
conflict with other people
so while you are in that state you will
have to have the state with respect to
someone in a given context
and it might fill the entirety of your
experience within this context and in
that moment
so you don't experience the separation
from self and other
in that state yeah and uh the question
is is this model correct
and it's correct if uh it's a mutual
thing
right and to the degree that it is
mutual you basically merge into the same
control unit
and you can experience being part of the
same control
but but there's a risk of divergence of
interests which you feel breaks the
the non-dual uh state
the the shared non-dual state that's
risk
and it might happen right you mess that
up
uh they might have conflicting interests
and uh these might
conflicting interests might emerge at
any point
okay so uh what you find in practice
that uh people
practice in non-duality they will still
have conflicts between each other that
will get rid of their non-dual
experience
uh is there anyone any one of these
questions about consciousness you'd like
to
to to to start with um anthony i have
some
some interest in starting with uh
whether the computationalist world
view actually explains the hard problem
of consciousness
i i would like to have a different uh
than the computationalist worldview if i
get anything else to work
i'll be glad it's not that i uh take
this worldview because i'm so enamored
with it
it's just that all the alternatives uh
that uh i have read about or that
occurred to me
don't work what's basically what's left
over
what is your issue with an idealist
world view that
is that in partis that is in part or in
the whole structured and implemented
via computation
and it could be that consciousness is
something that cannot be explained by
physics so it might be magic and i think
this is
the main appeal of idealism that it
seems to open up a window for magic
i think that uh the idealist worldviews
mostly come down to the idea that we
live in a dream
that we don't live in a physical
universe but in a dream universe
and it turns out i think that this is
correct right we obviously live in the
dream universe and
uh the dream is drammed by a mind on a
higher plane of existence
and now the question is how does
consciousness come about how is it
possible that the physical system
cannot can be experiencing things
and the answer is no it can't the
physical system cannot experience
anything experience is only possible in
a dream
it's a virtual property our existence as
experiencing beings is entirely virtual
it's not physical
which means we we are only experiencing
things
inside of the model it's part of the
model that we experience something
that for the neurons it doesn't feel
like anything to do this
for the brain it doesn't feel like
anything but it would be very useful for
the brain what it would be like to be a
person
so it generates a story about that
person about the feelings of that person
the relationship that this person
has with the environment and it acts on
that model
right and uh the model gets updated yeah
part of that behavior
it doesn't make sense why you say
neurons aren't conscious
but like the model is like a virtual
world which is what
consciousness is but it seems like
there's a gap there
between you know one neuron two neurons
uh n neurons the model and then how the
model
actually you know is grounded in being
as an actual experience rather than as
a philosophical zombie model
there is dynamics that happen inside of
your computer
a pattern that you project into your
computer to make
sense of what the transferring
transistor in this case are also set up
produce exactly that the reason why the
neurons are set up to produce this kind
of pattern so we can consistently
project it into is because the utility
of the pattern
is determined by the regulation tasks of
the brain right the brain needs to make
certain models in order to be effective
and the neurons are set up to produce
this model so you can consistently
project it into
but the update only happens inside of
the model it's only the story that gets
updated
and you can never leave this model you
you're only going to find you're locked
into the model you can never break out
into physics
because outside in physics it doesn't
feel like an economy yeah yes
nothing can feel anything out out there
right you cannot exist outside of the
dream you cannot wake up
you can only dream waking up and you
will be the next level dream
uh anthony is there anything uh you'd
like to ask
uh as we as we come closer to the end
here
well i i think a question that i'm i'm
has been on my mind a lot
in terms of ai uh that i'd be curious
of your views on is to what what things
are sort of necessarily coupled in
cognitive architectures and which ones
aren't in the in the particular sense
so so we have a a close connection
between our
sort of intelligence and effectiveness
as
agents who can understand the world and
act on it and have a world model
that is effective and what we would call
consciousness
which we also find very valuable
right morally valuable we think people
are
uh sort of morally important because
they have consciousness
most of our value derives from qualia in
consciousness you know whether they're
positive or negative
so there's this very tight connection in
us between
sort of capability and this thing that
we value
even in things that aren't that capable
so you know even
a child who's not particularly capable
of doing much we still very much value
the the positive quality that they
experience
so why should you know one question is
why should that be are those two
inexorably connected with each other
could we imagine you know a machine
system that was just as effective
uh as an agent intellectually and at
good making good decisions and getting
things done
but doesn't have the sort of
qualia that we care about a similar
question
to what degree does having qualia
require that we have positive and
negative valence to those quali in other
words could we have a
mind that is conscious of the same in
sort of the same manner that ours is
it introspects it feels like something
to be that thing in the sort of the same
way that it does us
but there's no particular preference for
positive or negative things there's no
suffering there's no joy
you know based on whether
you're pushing or pushing away or
pulling toward different qualia
and so arguably there there may or may
not be the sort of
moral status to the preferences of that
being it might have preferences
but maybe nobody has to care about them
and i'm curious as to how you
fit these things together in your view
because it
it seems like a lot of things that come
as a package in our mind
may or may not be inevitably you know
connected to each other
we can imagine different architectures
that have
different amounts of them um and and
might be designed to
to include some of them and not the
others
so uh we need first of all to have some
dimension of caring
once we have no dimension of caring left
um i think that even our perception
doesn't work anymore so
my only experience with enlightenment
states when you cycle through them is
that there
are degrees of disentangling yourself
from your own
motivations and we have many dimensions
of motivation obviously
and uh when we turn them off one by one
then it turns out that we still
perform mostly the same behaviors but
they are instrumental to
fewer and fewer motivations
right so uh for instance um jealousy is
a motivation that makes sense from an
evolutionary perspective
jealous agents might have more offspring
on their own so
jealousy gets bred into a population but
for the individual it's not beneficial
to be jealous
so if you because you're not going to
have more successful relationships due
to
jealousy uh you only have uh
bad emotions as well so if you can
disentangle yourself from your own
jealousy you might end up statistically
with slightly less offspring of your own
but individually uh the benefits
of far surpassing that so if you uh
behave as if you were jealous it's going
to only be in the context very uh
there is some other reason that
underlies this uh behavior
that makes it meaningful by itself and
um
so if you basically get rid of most of
your uh entanglements
um you end up with maybe uh just being
motivated by love with this willingness
to connect to others and serve the
sacred and if you give up on this one
then the only thing that's left is
aesthetics
that you try to find structure in the
patterns that you are seeing and when
you give up on that
then reality falls apart and becomes
white noise and you fall asleep
and so there needs to be a commitment to
how things ought to be
at some level in your mind i think to
keep it going
and you can become uh unaware of these
but something needs to keep going so if
you
actually are aware of the control that
you are exerting and if you learn to
modulate it
you can modulate it to the point where
basically everything becomes fuzzy
and um you stop controlling
your mental representations right that
would be the lowest level when you stop
representing the world because you no
longer care about
being able to track it then you will
stop
existing as any kind of sentient agent
so in this sense you need to have
certain motivations in order to make
behavior happen
and the question is what is the minimal
motivation that you would need to put
into an agent to make it sustainable if
it acts out of motivation
so if it's self-organized and autonomous
and
i think that fristen's theory is that
the minimization of free energy is
ultimately sufficient
so basically if you are able to
integrate the expected reward over a
long enough time frame
as evolution in some sense is implicitly
doing then the minimization of free
energy is going to give rise to all the
other
uh priors that we are born with as a
shortcut to improve the convergence of
the individual or the species
to that global behavior i don't know
whether the theory is called correct uh
it seems to be plausible to me i don't
see
many good alternatives but i suspect
that in the individual we need these
priors to
make behavior happen so if even if we
want to build an ai that is
learning statistics so uh
i would agree that you would need to uh
put in a number of uh things
for instance in your um language model
uh that are is going beyond
just uh minimizing the appraisal and uh
keeping track of the structure in the
data in order to make it really really
efficient it could be that you
would should need uh should add
additional things that it cares about
for instance
make an operational model of reality it
allows us to do things for instance gptc
would probably
get much better at arithmetic much
faster
if it was also incentivized to produce
certain results and
get rewards for producing these results
it cares about these
reports maybe one more thing
what you find in people are is the range
of possible states of minds that they
can't be in right you can be a
psychopath who is not caring about
qualia of others
and the type of qualia that we have are
the result of uh picking out things with
our conscious attention so we can form
index memories of them and have the
stream of consciousness
and what we pick out is part of our
perception of our mental stage or of the
world model that we have right so it's
always features in a much much larger
conceptual and perceptual graph that we
highlight
in their binding context and this
binding context also
contains a relationship to the relevance
that they have for us so
they always have some motivational color
otherwise we wouldn't pick them out with
our attention
that makes our qualia understand
specific
yeah though we certainly do value
certain qualia for their own sake i feel
i think humans are very intrinsically
motivated for
to for particular qualia to occur yes
but i suspect it's not quite for their
own sake it's either because they're
directly connected
to efferents and aversion so for
instance through certain foods or
body schemas and so on or uh because
they
are aesthetically relevant which means
that they help us to find better
representations or we anticipate that
they might
there's this quote that you said that i
really really liked
you said something like it's um you said
art is an algorithm falling in love with
the shape of the lost function itself
yes so it's i think that an artist in
some sense is
confused because the artist thinks that
the mental representation itself
is intrinsically meaningful it's not
instrumental to what you can do with it
it's not instrumental to the status that
you get or
the foot that you can get by selling it
or
the impression that you can make on
others or by what you learn from
applying it to your everyday life
but it's intrinsically important
so it's just the observation itself that
you need to capture and the ability to
capture it is the important thing
and i suspect that every functional mind
needs to have an art department
in the same way as every society needs
to have an academia that only cares
about truth regardless of it if it's
beneficial
for the individual academics and if you
lose this
you are going to lose an important part
of your regulation
for instance if you are running a
company and you are
coming from academia and you are a truth
seeker
you might be set up for failure right
because
a ceo is going to attack somebody with
finding truth if there is the truth
deficit
truth is not important for its own sake
if you're running a company if you try
to
use your resources in the best possible
way and the same thing
is going to apply to an ai that is going
to allocate resources
uh of itself to solving problems in its
environment
all right yoshi um i feel like i don't
know anything anymore
so i'm just gonna i'm gonna end my day
just being bewildered
uh at each moment
um
do you have anything else you wanna say
just to wrap up here
if you try to align yourself with
something that is smarter than you and
understands the conditions of your
existence in its own better than you do
uh it probably means that you have to
ask it what to do
and uh that is
the scary thing is that we might end up
building something that
has ultimately a different relationship
to reality than us and doesn't really
need us
and that is one of the big dangers i
think in
agi research and it's uh but it's the
same thing for
uh building in technological society you
always end up building golems
and uh then the question is can you stop
this golem or is it going to keep
working based on the program that you
gave it
until it's too late i don't know how to
solve that
all right josh
maybe you gave me an onological crisis
um okay i don't think so
i've been in an ontological crisis for
35 years or so so
it's just the normal state of affairs
okay it'll
maybe mine will go on for decades okay
thank you very much for coming on the
podcast
thanks for having me yeah uh talking to
you
all right